on va continuer à parler de ces
manifestations contre le contre la
chaîne
pour arte France Michel Fize Michel
c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous retrouver
sur le plateau
du
[Musique]
moment
économiques et
sociales
et politiques
au nom des Patriotes rien de nouveau il
y a 3 ans nous aurions pu faire le même
constat part aujourd'hui évidemment on
sort des moyennes un pouvoir d'achat qui
aurait reculer ou reculerai un petit peu
en réalité la ménagère quand elle fait
les courses elle s'aperçoit que il y a
des produits qui sont aujourd'hui
inaccessible d'autres qui ont fait des
bonds spectaculaire en parler du papier
toilette on parlait des pâtes on
pourrait citer beaucoup d'autres
beaucoup d'autres exemples donc
incontestablement
il y a un élargissement des inégalités
sociales je rappelle au passage que les
10 % des Français les plus pauvres gagne
environ 700 € par mois tandis que les 10
% les plus riches gagne 5000 € environ
net et après impôt on voilà l'étendue
l'étendue des dégâts donc il est évident
que les frites man du pouls le chat n'a
pas la même signification selon qu'on
est en haut ou en bas naturellement
pour la prochaine présidentielle
on parle beaucoup de fracture de la
France je vais vous en présenter une
autre dans ton parle pas beaucoup il y a
d'un côté le monde réel celui de la
souffrance de la misère de ceux qui
luttent au quotidien pour survivre tout
simplement et puis de l'autre côté il y
a le monde politique dans lequel est un
monde qui paraît à des années-lumière du
premier monde le monde des petites
phrases et petit intérêt parfum comment
pouvez-vous penser que les Français
comprennent que si l'on prend l'exemple
de la gauche 7 candidats on nous annonce
un troisième une troisième pour janvier
prochain à droite la droite nationale il
y a quand même 3 candidats entre Marine
Le Pen Éric Zemmour et puis du Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan tout ça fait désordre
voilà et surtout
c'est un monde qui est très très éloigné
qui est très très éloigné de réalité
quotidienne voilà donc je pense arrêtons
avec les moyennes arrêtons avec la
macroéconomie ce qui compte encore une
fois c'est les économies personne et
aujourd'hui de plus en plus français
sont dépourvus c'est les économies
personnel je voudrais dire quand même
parce que c'est peut-être un résumé
qu'on peut faire des des maintenant je
pense que nous vivons l'une des périodes
les plus sombres de l'histoire de France
parce que c'est qu'une crise qui dure
qui s'éternise Danton ne vois pas le
bout qui nous prend de tous les côtés
qui nous à l'improviste
des
réactions politiques je ne vois pas de
période de l'histoire effectivement
qu'il soit aussi anxiogène que celle
d'aujourd'hui alors évidemment j'entends
celles et ceux qui disent que la crise
c'est la crise épidémique est exagéré
voir même qu'elle a été fermé toutes
pièces pour l'histoire jugera peut-être
dans quelques décennies le fêter ses que
nous avons quand même 120 tu es à
milmort et même un peu plus aujourd'hui
que nous avons une menace qui pèse sur
chacun d'entre nous et tout ça dans un
climat dans un climat d'émotions mal
maîtrisée je pense que nous sommes pas
sous le joug de la dictature politique
nous sommes sous le joug des émotions
d'où cette espèce de Siri de mesures qui
passe improviser la réaction du moment
est sous le coup de l'émotion il comprit
au sommet de l'État
et
par exemple
de l'hôpital public
dans les politiques par rapport aux
mesures que l'on prend
manque de lit manque de personnel manque
de rémunération pour les pour les
soignants voilà sans compter toutes les
autres crise qui se déroule sous nos
yeux la crise agricole on en parle plus
beaucoup mais il existe existe toujours
la crise des magistrats on l'a vu il y a
quelques il y a quelques semaines on ne
parle plus des avocats mais il évoqua
sont aussi dans un parcours de
paupérisation croissants alors il est
évident que la crise de 2008 la crise
des subprimes enchaîner peut-être une
nouvelle crise du capitalisme du
capitalisme moderne à qui accroît encore
une fois les difficultés des uns et des
autres la mondialisation a peut-être des
vertus mais elle est aussi très bruyante
et notamment encore une fois au niveau
des statuts et des situations des
situations personnel et comme assez
incroyable que en 2021 bientôt 2022 il y
a des gens qui meurent de faim dans la
rue parce qu'ils peuvent pas se soigner
qui ne peuvent pas se loger qui se genou
ou moins jeune voilà c'est une situation
je dirais catastrophique et on ne le
dira jamais assez
je crois
que c'est ce
qui se passe autour de lui
et
après
quel temps il magine et imagine la suite
donc je pense que le défi c'est pour ça
que je parle de période sombre c'est
comment est-ce qu'on va sortir de tout
ceci est-ce que toutes les mesures et
compris des plus contraignante est
l'épouse attentatoire aux libertés
individuelles et comme donc l'obligation
vaccinale est-ce que tout ça va nous ça
va suffire à nous
sortir d'embarras j'en suis
malheureusement pas certain
mets selfie merci d'avoir été avec nous
cet après-midi
pour rt France merci d'avoir répondu